welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Esther Lam who is a visiting fellow
in East Asian Studies at the Macmillan
Center she heads the Northeast Asia team
within the asia-pacific section of the
United Nations Human Rights office a
journalist and researcher before joining
the United Nations MS Lam has published
extensively on Human Rights United
Nations and World Trade Organization
issues among her books are China and the
WTO a long march toward the rule of law
a practical guide to the WTO for human
rights advocates as lead author and SARS
and the w-h-o an untold story today
we'll talk with MS Lam about human
rights and multilateral Development
Bank's
also known as MDBs welcome is Lam Thank
You Marilyn let's start with the term
multilateral Development Bank's
what are they yeah so multilateral
Development Bank's they are
international financial institutions and
by definition they are multilateral
meaning their membership
multiple countries more than two as
their shareholders system more than two
countries as shareholders of this Bank
and usually a multilateral International
Development Bank they are established by
an international agreement we commonly
call them articles of agreement and
they're binding legal instrument for
their members which have ratified
agreement and so one might think oh so
hold on what exactly how is the
multilateral Development Bank different
from a commercial bank so primarily the
difference is that mandate is different
a multilateral Development Bank is
primary mandate is not about maximizing
profits for shareholders water.if
provides lungs and sometimes guarantees
for loans or other kind of financial
arrangement to finance projects finance
projects in a wide range of areas for
development and for raising the
standards of living for ending poverty
and this projects commonly like in areas
like energy transportation irrigation
and information technology and
communication how many are there well so
it depends on how strictly you different
from them actually they are like two
handfuls the most well-known one there's
the world bank and in actually almost
every region in fact I think every
region has has one you have the African
Development Bank the Asian Development
Bank inter-american Development Bank
Islamic Development Bank am I missing
all the European Investment Bank and
there are two important new additions to
this Bank in 2006 16 one is the BRICS
Bank
BRICS is the five countries Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa so
it used to be called BRICS Development
Bank now it's called new Development
Bank and the other one is initiated by
China became operational in 2016 it's
called Asian infrastructure investment
bank which has a focus on infrastructure
development and they also sub Regional
Development Bank's as well like in East
Africa in Central America so quite a
number of them are these banks part of
the United Nations or are they part of
countries who oversees the rules and
regulations of the bank
yeah mostly they're not part of the
United Nations but they cooperate very
closely with the United Nations some of
them actually the establishment itself
can could be chased back to the regional
economic commissions in different
regions of the UN but who the good
question is who oversees the operations
and rules and regulations of the banks
so I mentioned all earlier there there
are the articles of agreement so all
this man banks they have a board of
governors who are representatives of the
countries that are shareholders and then
so they oversees the operation of the
bank and then you have a bank president
so you have two Secretariat that one's
the daily operations and the people who
run the bank would they be more
governmental officials or from the
private sector or is it a mix between
you know corporate you know CEOs of
corporations and government officials to
put people who are doing the daily
operations of the staff secretary of
these banks they are professional
they're experts so in a way they are
civil servants where there is a
multilateral banks and then for the
governance many of them are
representatives of government you know
they are related to like the Treasury or
finance department and so but each bank
has its unique arrangement but overall
you have the gist of this setting okay
so what are new somewhat alluded to the
role of MDBs but can you be a little bit
more specific as to what they're doing
yeah for example when we look at well
give a sense of about the contribution
ah yeah the size of their finance No so
when we look at for in the past between
year 2000 2015 when we had the
Millennium well we learned him and
development goes so the 50
years so there's a figure that came out
from interagency task force between the
multilateral banks and the UN so the
finance support for development from
these banks increased from I think 50
billion in 2000 per per year to 127
billion per year so they are providing a
lot of supports so as to what kind of
project so is different way so sometimes
you have like the World Bank and the
Asian Development Bank they also do
projects like has to do with healthcare
system they provide also in addition to
fundings technical assistance and
expertise some banks have built were--we
them or you know hydropower so the days
of very wide range of different projects
we're talking about here and who
determines what projects get funded oh
good question
so clearly countries and different
countries apart they submit proposals
for funding and then each bank will have
a mechanism you know to review there
would be a standard I would imagine a
template you know the requirement and
the project and why their justification
and then we will be revealed by you know
professional staff of each Bank and then
the ultimate efficient of course who
West with report but oftentimes I think
most of the groundwork and verification
the screening is done at the
professional Secretariat level okay so
let's talk about specific examples of
how human rights fit into economic
development and the MDBs
can you cite some specific examples yeah
all right so human rights Holly
fitting okay well and first of all I
guess we should talk about human what do
you what do we mean by human rights I
would imagine you know one of the
missions of the MDGs is to raise people
up to improve their quality of life and
that can be in many different regards
from climate change to healthcare so can
you can you give some examples of maybe
some of the programs that have worked
particularly well okay okay so there are
two I can see that two aspects of your
question right when this how human why
is irrelevant related to economic
development right
the other is then what's the role of MDB
multilateral Development Bank in this so
I actually would try to turn it a wand
and think of about this way you know we
don't just pursue economic development
for the sake of right but it's not the
meaning itself and so when we ask
ourselves what is economic development
for so let's bring it down to our
day-to-day life away so primarily it is
about you know health care food
adequate housing having access to clean
water sanitation facilities so in and
this examples I mentioned they are all
internationally recognized and legally
guarantee human rights alienable yeah
they're in the they're in different
human rights instruments law and they're
in the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights which is turning 70 today yeah
what today not today
this year yeah so so there's an
intrinsic link when you think of it it's
not just economic development for the
sake of it and I do believe there's a
global consensus now when we talk about
the
element or economic development we're
talking about inclusive sustainable
development work so no one should be
left behind in today's world and sadly
many are still left behind I think I
just went a report yesterday was hot
wealth 50% of it belongs to 1% exactly
world's population so many people were
left behind and and I can go on and on
about you know human rights and what we
should do about it because this is what
my office does where I work but when
when we come back to the multilateral
Development Bank role is interesting
because after the 2016 - the agreement
with the consensus on the sustainable
development goals which we call the 2030
agenda so we're talking about a global
consensus where we go from here
2016 2 2013 we talk about sustainable
development so there are 17 goals
covering a wide range of areas with the
hopes that those goals are met by 2030
exactly yes exactly so the motor lateral
development Development Bank's got
together through those examples I
mentioned earlier and they've identified
you know some areas that you they can
make a contribution so for example let's
talk about money because that's what
banks of how I'd make a contribution so
there's you and estimate if we are to
achieve these sustainable development
goals we're talking about five to seven
trillion US dollars per year so it's far
beyond any life for an office or
assistance program or any one single
country can do and these banks they
membership a multilateral
countries they're different countries so
that's why it's so important to get to
and do this together and there's some
somatic areas that which which really
jump out to us the needs for example
let's think about force displacement
whether it's because of conflict natural
disasters so this Bank this multilateral
Development Bank's can do a lot to help
finance and developed maintain and build
institutional capacity for this fragile
and conflict affected states you know so
to help tackle into the force
displacement issue and when we look at
the state of the world today you can see
also when large number of people
dispraise then the influx into another
country or the host community is also a
huge challenge
so these banks can do a lot to help also
to strengthen the capacity of the host
community to handle though these
challenges who this is one one area i
think there was one concrete pledge by
the multilateral banks to do this
together they trying to have a
humanitarian development partnership so
to look at these areas of work in the
humanitarian summit last year
another thing that pretty obvious to all
of us and its climate change a lot of
projects and program work needs to be
done to mitigate climate change require
investment and this is another area as
well I'm aware of the multilateral
Development Bank's are trying to work on
better and also in a more in sync manner
because you have the green fund and you
have other other funding opportunities
out there but they heal the demands and
is huge and then they're trying to align
themselves and how to do it then they're
doing it in a way that's most effective
and in line with the Paris agreement
okay yeah well lastly allow me to
mention also infrastructure investment
in infrastructure is vital vital
wirings of human life the evidence sure
when it comes to you know education SS
there are lots of basic needs and
infrastructure plays a huge role and
there's a huge gap also in
infrastructure development and when you
say infrastructure development do you
mean roads no people can get around i
know particularly in africa that is an
issue is there anywhere else in the
world that infrastructure is a concern
yeah yeah many parts like Asia as well
and so the sustainable development goals
one of it has to it's about building
resilient infrastructure and then
transportation like roads where was one
is one thing but infrastructure also
includes like energy irrigation like
water system in fact information and
communication technology infrastructure
is also a very very important part of
infrastructure as well it is so
important though that there's a new
forum among the multilateral Development
Bank banks and the United Nation well of
an agency that was launched last year in
a polar belief is a global
infrastructure forum exactly to pull
together the expertise and see how best
to address these leads and to finance
these projects in a smart way and for
example the newly created Asia
infrastructure investment bank it's now
financing a number of projects
co-financing with the Asian Development
issue Development Bank and the World
Bank as well so they're cooperating the
new one the existing existing one so it
is an important and challenging time
right what are some of the challenges
that MDB is face mmm there are plenty
and you know there are also critics out
there
about you know governance issues
political issues yeah but but let us
focus on maybe the human rights
perspective as we are talking about
multilateral Development Bank's and
human rights put it this way the there
are many active civil society actors
angio's worldwide they dedicate their
efforts to monitor the work and
operations of multilateral Development
Bank's so that they truly deliver on
their promises and at the same time that
projects they support do no harm to
human ways right why so because we
credibly evidence shows that human
rights can be and in fact have been
violated sometimes in the context of
projects financed by multilateral
Development Bank's and this current this
violations went from for forced
displacement for eviction child labor
force labor and also affecting the local
communities the
ss2 livelihood and how about the
indigenous populations and the people so
there are there are issues and I think
what these banks they are trying to
address them as well and they they have
certain safeguards usually calls also
and environmental safeguards to help
kind of due diligence to help to make
sure ok these projects won't come to any
harm to human rights and I'm from a
human rights perspective more can be
done
mm-hmm does the he does the UN play a
role and also monitoring
well for our officers we have three
presences so we do monitoring of human
rights situations but losses not
necessarily only focusing on
multilateral Development Bank's and but
at the norm setting level our office the
office of the UN High Commissioner for
Human Rights has been fairly active in
providing expertise advise and
submissions to all sorts of multilateral
Development Bank's so when it comes to
their their different mechanisms like
the safeguard and our environmental and
social safeguards I mentioned you know
both the new one by the Asia
infrastructure investment bank and also
the one that's revised and also
literally revised by the World Bank
Group so that that we do and one of the
course main suggestions as also by NGOs
is Human Rights me to be explicitly
mentioned in the safeguards and our
environmental and social safeguards
because okay when they borrow clearly
the responsibility to implement the
projects well so if the borrower the one
who bore away the country even but as
the lender in this case multilateral
Development Bank if they're not vigilant
or if they're not fair explicit in their
lungs agreement grants agreement about
human rights then it won't be taken
seriously while you have other
challenges in implementing a big
projects so one one of the ways to do
this is to to to have very explicit
reference to him arise in the in the
safeguards rules and when watching the
the proposal submission for grants in
ohms also look into the human rights
assessment there should be risk
assessment how likely this
in fact the life of the local population
there it's their meaningful consultation
like with the local population
communities indigenous people and and
also if things go wrong
instead we dress mechanism you know how
can people be compensated how how to
avoid you know this from happening it's
a lot of concrete things that can be
done and so clearly the way to go
forward is to work together I don't
think well this is my personal will I
think the debate has gone beyond whether
multilateral Development Bank's should
be vigilant and you know should be
careful whether project is supported
their supporting can adversely affect
human rights I think that we've we've
gone beyond that everyone agrees you
know clearly but that should be done yes
exactly what this otherwise why doing
this why can you do this yes yeah but
then the question is how you know how to
get there yeah and we still have a long
way to go okay
you are at Yale as a visiting scholar
and I know you're doing a little bit of
work on the IAB the newest MDB so can
you tell us a little bit of what you're
doing while you're here at Yale yeah
so I'm here for a semester on sabbatical
from my work with the Human Rights
office
I'm normally based in Geneva Switzerland
and so my research here concerns aii be
so Asian infrastructure investment bank
elicited by China and this bankers is
very significant and interesting in many
ways for example his membership includes
a wide range of countries of different
levels of development and from all
regions of the world
now with Canada Canada having a party
Jordan our North America is included so
for example for the g7 industrialized
countries all out there except the
United States and Japan so you have UK
Germany Italy Canada and and then you
have developed or fairway developed
country like the Scandinavians are in
Sweden and another sign then you have
which countries like Switzerland
Luxembourg and you have mid-range
developing countries Indonesia Egypt Sri
Lanka and then the LDCs the less
developed countries also from all
regions Ethiopia is in Afghanistan is in
Nepal is in so the membership itself is
very interesting because when we look
getting from a human rights perspective
we were talking about earlier know all
these member states they have human
rights obligations they have rectified
international human rights law and you
know in in what they do you know you
know they they need to be furnish its
talents through a multilateral
Development Bank still they have to be
in compliance with their human rights
obligations so there's one another
another thing is the which of the bank
so he has a Asia focus on infrastructure
development where he's a very wide focus
and many people look at the Asian
infrastructure Development Bank together
with China's well Tam world initiative
which is also a very wide-ranging mega
project and initiative and so but at the
same time it has potential to to to
support projects outside strictly Asia
in fact in September it has approved a
project to support the project in Egypt
yeah it's about if I remember correctly
about water and energy and food
so again it's about how this can play a
big role about connectivity so so this
is the area I'm looking into and I must
say I've been very very fortunate that
we enjoy these excellent
interdisciplinary environment here at
yellow and I've had fairly interesting
discussions with other scholars from you
know law school and if you know the man
in center comes from East Asian Studies
and beyond and I'm very happy and
thankful for this opportunity you know
for my employer the UN and for my host
the Milan center so thank you very much
and we are happy to have you here thank
you very much for sharing some of your
work with us today
Thank You Marilyn for more information
about Ms Lam please visit our website at
macmillan report jled you be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale
you